there's something special here where
where people approach the work we do
with very considered approach to
creating characters that are obviously
you can connect with and that are
lovable and then there's just good old
craft
I think Augmon likes putting in the
hours and crafting something as
beautiful as they can and I hope this
has integrity and craft in it in the end
[Music]
[Music]
America has Pixar Japan has Studio
Ghibli and Europe Europe has aardman
from Wallace and Gromit to morph to
creature comforts to chicken run admin
has been entertaining families using
stop-motion models for 46 years and it's
up there with the most talented
Animation Studios in the world it's also
a studio that has a special place in my
own heart Allen was founded and
continues to be based in my hometown the
beautiful city of Bristol in southwest
England I walked past the studio every
day on my walk home from school staring
through the window at the iconic
characters the my granddad would sit me
in front of every Saturday now a decade
later Hartman is making its first
in-house console game 1111 memories
retold snorting in time for the first
world war centenary 1111 is a huge
departure of Martin's usual style of
uplifting family-friendly comedy a
collaboration with digits are a French
studio led by valiant hearts director
Johan Fenice the game is a decidedly
more somber affair with an inventive
painterly art style and a medium aardman
has barely ever dipped its clay toes
into to find out why Ardoin embarks on
such a radical journey I went home to
Bristol to meet the team and over the
next seven or so minutes we'll explore
why Arvin wanted to make eleven eleven
why now and how on earth an
oscar-winning animation studio makes a
video game
[Music]
despite its animation ruse
Herman has made video games before over
50 of them in fact
however pretty much all of these have
been small-scale flash games mobile apps
educational games or licensing deals
with other developers 11:11 on the other
hand represents the first time Arvind
has brought development of a console
game in-house which begs the question
why not so the interactive table where I
work you know as we talked about we've
been making sort of smaller games and
educational games and things for our own
properties but you know like web games
that's quite a while we know the
department's full of gamers you know and
it's always something that we've wanted
to do you know take that next step to a
larger level and when this kind of
opportunity came up and like it just
seemed like the perfect thing for us to
do because working with yoen you know
you look at its preview like valiant
hearts and previous things he's worked
on it's games which of really good
stories by them and Alban is heart what
we kind of pride ourselves on is like
really good characters and really great
storytelling it was during the games for
change festival in Paris three years ago
and they were one people from Earthman
in the in this event we talked about
world war 1 because with you know
British it's something we have in common
and an Earthman wanted to to go more
into video games try to do video games
because there are very famous animation
studio and so it was a perfect fit with
digital studio to work with such a
famous studio in animation I think the
important thing there are different kind
of games you have agency inside that
story you know
so that can let you take part in the
story in in ways that you wouldn't with
a more passive experience so I think
that what that enables you to do is make
choices you know and then see the
ramifications of those choices so what
games are you do is let people make
those choices and experience the
outcomes of their own choices you know
they have responsibilities then for the
what's happening to the characters so
this seemed like the perfect first step
into this world of something we really
want to be doing more of you know we
obviously were most well known for
stop-motion animation but you know we
have a large computer graphics
department for like linear animation we
have a large interactive team and they
just seemed like we wanted to take all
the
skills we've got and now take them to
that next level of like console level
games because it's something we're all
really interested in in an animated film
you can pre render everything by the
time the movie hits theaters everything
is wrapped up into a neat little package
and the studio's job is done in a video
game the studio's work must react to you
the player this presented more
challenges than the team at Ardoin
initially anticipated and Fenice even
had to help coach his colleagues through
the process this is something that was
new for for Artman so of course it was
it was most troubling technically for
sure but the benefit of the direction
the quality of the animation in the art
was like so huge that
if you make the balance it's so good
obviously everything in a game engine
has to be real-time so trying to achieve
that trying to achieve this quite unique
look that we've done inside a game
engine is was a challenge you know even
to get it to run trying to do everything
real-time it's very very different from
being able to take five minutes ten
minutes an hour per frame that you're
rendering you know we have a render farm
for our CG people and it's over there
rendering something out they send it
away a few hours later you get it back
Edmund had never made a game of this
scale before so understandably lenten
Fenice and his team's technical
experience digits are is only three
years old but it's full of industry
veterans and their extensive experience
was used to help coach Hardman through
the process
the British studio on the other hand
brought its trademark storytelling craft
and visual design to create fleshed out
characters and a unique art style it's
too early to tell how the finished
product will turn out but just the
process of making eleven eleven has
helped Hardman in its other endeavors
for me it's it's very benefit like
something that can bring new ideas and
new art forms into video game in fact
it's good to blend these different draws
and people from other industries than
only video games so they can bring those
reference of painters of school tools
this kind of things that we don't think
too much when you are into the video
game bubble and it it leads to something
very unique and the visual of the game
is very unique because of of those
external inputs into the project but
then also because you know games have to
kind of have to be on the forefront of
Technology
then I think that then they can give
back to other industries like film and
things like that it's quite interesting
at young on our last film on early man
the interactive team here we'd actually
developed at the our tool for them to
use even so there's these big football
scenes inside the film and the guys are
running around on the unlocks you
stop-motion football pitch with the
stadium itself is CG but then for the
animators to be able to see like the
shots where they see where the stadium
isn't that we made them a little at the
arm package we have an oculus where they
the animator could put the headset on
kind of put the camera where they want
it and see it from the viewpoint of the
characters inside so that was a literal
like physical Oscar okay well how can we
improve your filmmaking process with
kind of the interactive tools that we've
got Armand has built up a mastery of
animation it's been working on feature
films and television for 46 years as one
countless BAFTAs and Oscars and as a
reputation as a leader in the animation
space it's not at that stage with video
games yet but the studio has been
working on making better more believable
and more interesting characters since
1972 that should put it in good stead
for making 11 11 and more video games in
the future I hope in our future we've
got a chance to try and really make
people laugh um but I've noticed
delivering humorous situations in
computer games can actually be very hard
things so in some ways that maybe we shy
away from that as our first attempt and
underlying a lot of oddments work is a
purpose it's a reason and we like the
idea of getting up in the morning and
not just making entertainment but making
something that we feel should be in the
world I can see somewhere in the future
there being something that people look
at and go oh Hardman must have made that
I'd love to get the physical craft the
admin has somewhere into the work we do
but at the same time when you actually
look into the depth of art and all the
stuff that comes out outside of the
wallace and gromit sand Sean the sheep's
you realise more that you normally kind
of see so I hope there'll be plenty of
innovation in there as well eleven
eleven represents new grain for admin
not only is this a new medium for much
of the team but it's also a huge
departure in tone and style from their
previous work is an experiment then but
a calculated one once they're
comfortable with the process of making
games the studio wants to make something
more quintessentially aardman that's
what really excites me I want to see
those wide eyes and giant teeth
the indescribable stop-motion magic and
stories there are equal parts funny and
moving for kids and adults alike
something my granddad could appreciate
as much as he did a grand day out or
perhaps something to inspire the next
generation of Wanderers on their way
home from school
[Music]
all right guys thank you very much for
watching let me know your thoughts on
I've been getting into video games in
the comments section below or you can
come find me on Twitter I might dare
said but until then I'll see you next
time